[Music]
I'm just really emotional today
oh I'm such a mess it's okay it's hard
to understand the context to go around
you know the different scenes what was
your reaction watching back you know the
episodes in the pods and then a little
bit in Mexico too obviously people
online want to tag you with the sort of
like this mean girl tag I think what
makes me nervous is having to really
rely on what's internal yeah if no one
likes my insides
what
was your reaction when you saw people
were reacting that way
um it was really hard
I mean I know and my friends my family
know that's not me
um but it's like you know even watching
it was hard for me to watch I think I
would have felt the same way
sorry it's okay
I've just been really emotional today
that's okay
um
yeah it's just it's hard to watch
you know
it's hard to understand the context like
around you know the different scenes
um but I just took time to reflect and
you know what was going on in that
moment you know why does it seem like
that like why am I laughing and I think
a lot of time I use like laughter as a
good nervousness
you know I think about when I you know
walked in from the pods and I came and
Jackie was on the couch you know I
didn't really understand or know that
she was you know upset
um because I was so wrapped up in my own
head I just had a conversation with
Kwame I want to talk to my friend about
it I was nervous and scared I was
excited to
you know tell Paul that I want to just
move forward with just him I was really
excited and I think
I didn't
I didn't take a step outside of myself
to realize that there was something else
going on you know around me
um you know moments like that it's like
oh God why didn't I pay more attention
to other people but it was never meant
to be nasty or laugh at anyone in pain I
even like watching the scene with Amber
um
you know when she had come back in from
her conversation with Paul I know I was
all frustrated and scared and upset like
why'd it take so long you sit with me
yeah I cannot be on it okay it's okay I
ended it really quick and I was
they're really strong in my conviction
that I was going with Paul and I was
just so scared that maybe he changed his
mind
and
obviously Irena and I you know very
caselessly wanted to listen and see what
was going on
I never knew that she was crying or
upset I knew that she had other
connections you know me and Amber
decided early on that we weren't going
to talk about our connections because we
knew we had some of the same ones
and so I didn't realize you know the
gravity of the situation
and watching him back it just seems
really you know selfish and I know when
she rounded the corner and she was
crying like I immediately
was taking it back like oh my God she's
really upset like in one hand I'm like
oh my God Paul like you know did end it
with her and my heart I'm a little happy
and
and Senior cry was just terrible
and you know I hugged her and I told her
I was so sorry and
you know she told me she was happy for
me she healed it with a lot of Grace
um
but you know it doesn't change the fact
that you know
I was more worried about myself than
anyone else and it's you know it was
hard to watch and one side of me is so
happy like relieved maybe if you could
go back and change the way that you
react in those situations
I'm sure you would
would you
I wish I was
more supportive
of other people's Journeys even if it
crossed over with mine I never wanted to
be mean or hurt Amber or hurt Jackie
it's just I was caught up in my own
story I was
you know trying to get
you know this happy ending and I think I
was more interested in what was going on
with me than anyone else yeah and while
it wasn't meant to be mean
it wasn't it didn't it wasn't caring or
you know helping them through you know
their difficult time you put it out on
Instagram saying you apologized to cast
mates who did you reach out to who did
you feel like you needed to you were
compelled to reach out to and say yeah
hey I'm sorry
yeah
um you know
when things were happening I definitely
had conversations with
Chelsea
um the disrespect shown at the pool
party is embarrassing
obviously we were all drinking and
but it doesn't you know erase the fact
that it was inappropriate I think it was
disrespectful to her and to Paul
um so I apologized to her
Arena recently put out a video
apologizing do you guys told are you
guys still in touch are you guys still
friendly
it's okay can we can somebody grab some
tissues or something
thank you just like talking about it out
loud it's just like
emotional yeah of course
it's difficult very few people know what
it's like to be in in this position
obviously you know whatever happened at
the pool party maybe it wouldn't happen
if I wasn't
doing God knows what you know
it's hard to say but you know it didn't
hurt me because I felt like she was you
know my closest friend at the time I
think that's the reason why I was so
upset
do I still talk
yeah we still talk
um
I think this has been you know Growing
Experience for both of us and I think
you know we both you know need to work
on ourselves you know just like everyone
else
um but hopefully we can you know help
each other do that yeah has there been
anything that surprised you about the
feedback that you've gotten on social
media about from all this
um I think I wasn't expecting
just because I know how things were in
reality I wasn't necessarily expecting
it to be like this because I knew my
intentions
but when I watched the show I understand
where people are coming from yeah and
obviously it's really hurtful and it
sucks to read
um
but I understand I mean
people you know they're watching the
show and they feel like you know they're
a part of it and they're hurt and
you know that's
okay what I heard from my sources where
at least on her end it's not very
genuine like in in terms of her
intentions of being on the show Natalie
from season two said that she wasn't
sure that you were there for the right
reasons maybe you had a possible
ulterior motive did you I mean what do
you have a response to that
I think that she should have taken the
time to talk to me or Paul before saying
something like that I mean she knows she
went through this experience she knows
how you know things can be portrayed or
feel I mean I'm sure she went through
the same thing with Shane so I thought
you know I think that maybe she should
have given me a little Grace especially
in something that's so incredibly untrue
yeah would you go on her and UT's
podcast and talk talk this out if
invited
um
yeah I would consider it yeah
you know at this point it's like
things aren't going to be
checked and sourced it doesn't give me a
lot of hope that it's something that I
would want to put myself in yeah yeah
you know if I can't believe in where
this information is coming from why
would I subject myself to that for me I
like I think I feed really hard off like
People's Energy I would kind of maybe
consider myself like an empath so it's
like important to surround myself with
like really genuine people do you feel
like a changed person from you know
point A to point B in this journey
I think you know on par with how crazy
the trajectory is with relationships it
also is for growth
I feel like I matured a lot throughout
the process I have a lot more to go
um but I feel you're put in so many hard
situations where you really just have to
dig deep in yourself and you know I did
and I did the best I could and I think
that I did you know have a journey you
know in myself
as well what's your headspace around
relationships with other cast members
now I mean I can understand why you'd be
like
I love you guys but this is painful and
difficult for me and I don't want to I
don't know or are you guys bonded
Forever For This by this experience yeah
um
I think
with how everything kind of came out
I think it's made it more difficult to
be close with people
um
you know
a lot of us were you know close out of
the pods and we kept in touch
um you know I've hung out with some of
the girls and you know maintained
relationships I think that there's just
so much going on right now for all of us
that I don't want to like get in
anyone's way like I don't want to
like if someone doesn't want to talk
with me like that's okay like I want you
to have your journey
um I want you to do what's best for you
um but you know a lot of the people you
know on the show are really great people
and there's definitely no writing them
off as friends
foreign